Okay, so let's have a
look at this.
this
figure represents
the probability tree
for two events
Where the events are just flipping two coins?
And we have four possible outcomes from flipping two coins.
Either we get two heads or two tails.
or a tails in the head
or heads and a tails.
Now you remember this again calculating probability
is very simple.
chosen number of outcomes over the total possible number
of outcomes
So obviously if you if you want to know what is a probability
of getting two heads.
There is one outcome. We have four possible outcomes.
So that's one over four.
Okay, and if we are particular about
the order?
In which we get a heads or tails. Well, then we
would have two separate outcomes.
So getting a tails and heads.
Or a heads on the Tails. These are considered two
separate outcomes.
now, let's see why we don't want to add and why we
have to multiply
the straight line represents one coin
the possible outcomes of the first coin
the dashed lines represent the possible
outcomes of the second coin.
If we flip the first coin.
Now we get ahead.
the other coin
also has two other possible outcomes.
So let's say we flip the second out we flip the second coin.
Which also has 50% probability and we get a heads.
if we count
these two numbers or I should say if we add these two numbers.
we get a 1
or a hundred percent probability which doesn't
make sense.
But if you multiply 50.5 times 0.5
we get 25.
0.25
which does make sense?
the point of multiplying
is to
account for
all the possible outcomes multiplication is
another way to add
or I should say multiplication is a
sequence of addition operations.
So this is one.
perspective